where do you get your news from Mostly
the internet we're in an interesting
time I think people have more access to
information than in the history of
humankind the pros of the internet is
you can find anything you want to the
cons of the internet is you can find
anything that you want to if you go
there with some type of confirmation
bias let me just tell anybody what
they're going to find on the internet
exactly what they're looking for you can
get lost in fake news satire sites that
sometimes are so ridiculously good
they're hard to tell that they're satar
you'll come on to traditional media
Outlets I'm sorry if this day and age if
people don't realize that everybody and
that message is bought and paid for I
don't know how to help you because it's
right there in your face you'd have to
be blind and not see it and I don't have
a problem with people getting news from
either one of those sources let's just
recognize there's a slant on it and a
bias and also they're in the business of
selling ads just like TV